[Music]
is it really surprising that a movie
starring the two most iconic superheroes
in the world would be controversial real
answer come on Dark Knight trilogy
Christopher Nolan's totally involved in
these you're just a bunch Marvel fanboy
ant-man looks stupid there I said he has
to be fine well stop with the brooding
Snyder's just a guy trying to make a
good movie it looks like sucker punch
[Applause]
that's how it started
Warner Brothers casting Ben Affleck as
Batman that turned fanboys cruel get
ready
to debate a teaser that will probably
generate more drama than the movie
itself tell me is my Ragland voice
better than christian bale's
[Music]
I mean it has to be right Batman
and featuring Superman rush to the
Justice League you're just saying that
cuz the Star Wars trailer is so awesome
it's looking good so the movie comes out
give it time
I'm just saying well that was fun let us
know if you want more honest teasers in
the comments below if you want to watch
us to fate whether the trailer was
badass or sucked check out this week's
movie fights in the box to the left and
lastly don't miss out on future honest
surprises please go and subscribe go
ahead
we'll wait any day now and the gorse
guys get other stuff to do